the coefficients and choose K that we
calculated in the previous segment are
known as the binomial coefficients they
are intimately related to certain
probabilities associated with coin
tossing models the so called binomial
probabilities this is going to be our
subject we consider a coin which we toss
and times in a row independently for
each one of the tosses of this coin we
assume that there is a certain
probability P that the result is heads
which of course implies that the
probability of obtaining tails in any
particular toss is going to be 1 minus P
the question we want to address is the
following we want to calculate the
probability that in those n independent
coin tosses we're going to observe
exactly K heads let us start working our
way towards the solution to this problem
by looking first at a simple setting and
then move on so let us answer this
simple question what is the probability
that we observe this particular sequence
of course here we take an equal to 6 and
we wish to calculate this probability
now because we have assumed that the
coin tosses are independent we can
multiply probabilities so the
probability of this sequence is equal to
the probability that the first toss is
heads times the probability that the
second toss is tails which is 1 minus P
times the probability that the third
toss is tails which is 1 minus P times
the probability of heads times the
probability of heads times the
probability of heads and by collecting
terms this is P to the fourth times 1
minus P to the second power more
generally if I give you a particular
sequence of heads and
as in this example and I asked you what
is the probability that this particular
sequence is observed then by
generalizing from this answer or from
the derivation of this answer you see
that you're going to get P to the power
number of heads and the reason is that
each time that there is a head showing
up in this sequence there is a
corresponding factor of P in this
numerical answer and then there are
factors associated with tails each tail
contributes a factor of 1 minus P and so
we are going to have here 1 minus P to a
power equal to the number of tails now
if I ask you about the probability of a
particular sequence and that particular
sequence has happens to have exactly K
heads what is the probability of that
sequence well we already calculated what
it is it's the previous answer except
that we use the symbol K instead of just
writing out explicitly number of heads
and the number of tails is the number of
tosses
- how many tosses resulted in heads now
we're ready to consider the actual
problem that we want to solve which is
to calculate the probability of K heads
the event of obtaining K hands can
happen in many different ways
any particular K hat sequence makes that
event to occur any particular K hat
sequence has a probability equal to this
expression the overall probability of K
heads is going to be the probability of
any particular K hat sequence times the
number of K had sequences that we have
now the reason why we can carry out this
argument is the fact that any K had
sequence has the same probability
otherwise we wouldn't be able to write
down an answer which is just the product
of two terms but because every K had
sequence has the same probability to
find the overall probability we take the
probability of each one of them and
multiplied with the number of how many
of these we have so to make further
progress now we need to calculate the
number of possible K had sequences how
many are there
well specifying a K had sequence is the
same as the following you think of
having n time slots these time slots
corresponds to the different doses of
your coin and to specify a K head
sequence you need to tell me which ones
of these slots happen to contain a head
you need to tell me K of those slots so
in other words what you're doing is
you're specifying a subset of the set of
these and slots a subset that has K
elements you need to choose K of the
slots out of the N and tell me that
those case Lots have heads that's the
way of specifying a particular K had
sequence so what's the number of K had
sequences well it's the same as the
number of ways that you can choose K
slots out of the n slots which is our
binomial coefficient and choose K
therefore the answer to our problem is
this expression here times and choose K
which is shown up here at this point we
can pause and consider a simple question
to check your understanding of the
binomial probabilities